gedenken an die opfer von halle
bundesweit versammeln sich menschen zu
mahnwachen und gebeten
der tatverdächtige hat inzwischen
gestanden
friedensnobelpreis für abu ahmed das
komitee in oslo würdigt äthiopiens
ministerpräsidenten für seine verdienste
um den frieden mit dem nachbarn eritrea
keime in der milch wegen
verunreinigungen wird fettarme
frischmilch in ganz deutschland
zurückgerufen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten am freitag sport gibt's
auch mit norbert lehmann einzigen werden
doch von mir
der mutmaßliche attentäter von halle hat
ein umfassendes geständnis abgelegt das
heißt er hat nicht nur den anschlag auf
die synagoge und den mord an zwei
menschen zugegeben sondern auch seinen
judenhass und eine rechtsextreme
einstellung als motiv genannt
sein ziel sei es gewesen so die
ermittler
in der synagoge ein massaker anzurichten
überall in deutschland ist die
solidarität mit den opfern riesengroß
und auch mit den gruppen in der
gesellschaft die der täter im blick
hatte menschenketten und mahnwachen gab
es zb in münchen und in bochum
viele bürger möchten zeigen dass
fremdenhass und antisemitismus in
deutschland nichts zu suchen haben ganz
fritsche mit schalom frieden ziehen die
menschen vor die synagoge in halle
mehrere hundert sind am abend gekommen
um ihre solidarität mit den terroropfern
und der jüdischen gemeinschaft
auszudrücken
auf initiative der kirchen wollen sie
sich wie ein schutz ring um das
gotteshaus stellen
wir wollen auch in zeichen setzen dafür
dass wir nicht nur gemeinsam zusammen
stehen in dieser gesellschaft sondern es
geht auch darum dass jeder gläubiger und
alle gläubigen egal jetzt welcher
religion sie angehören sicher ihre
gottesdienste und ihre religion feiern
und auch ausüben können das zeichen der
solidarität für die jüdische gemeinde in
halle dringend nötig der vorsitzende
überlegt nicht erst seit der tat
deutschland zu verlassen
zu groß sei der hass in der gesellschaft
nicht nur gegen juden
also ich kann nur über mich sprechen ich
überlege ob ich persönlich nicht jetzt
aber solche gedanken hps und coverage
der festgenommene stephan b hat die
terrortat inzwischen gestanden und
bestätigt auch sein
rechtsextremistisches antisemitisches
motiv der haftbefehl liegt ihm
zweifachen mord und sieben fachen
mordversuchs zu lasst den ganzen tag
über finden in halle gedenkt aktionen
statt
hier am marktplatz demonstrieren die
hallenser am nachmittag gegen
fremdenfeindlichkeit und antisemitismus
ich persönlich sehr große solidarität
von vielen hallensern die hier
zusammenkommen und gemeinsam auch dafür
eintreten dass rechts und antisemitismus
in dieser stadt eben keinen platz haben
soll
die menschen in halle rücken in diesen
stunden näher zusammen nach dem tag der
ratlosigkeit ist heute der tag des
zusammenstehen gegen hass zu dem
attentat und den konsequenzen daraus
gibt es ein was nun mit innenminister
seehofer gleich nach dieser sendung die
kritik am einmarsch türkischer truppen
in syrien hält an
auch nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg
appellierte an die regierungen angabe so
wörtlich zurückhaltend zu agieren
die angst vor einem krieg hat es 70.000
menschen in die flucht getrieben vor
allem in zwei regionen im norden des
landes
die türkischen luft und bodentruppen
sollen dort die wasserversorgung demmel
kraftwerke und ölfelder getroffen haben
glück weil chaos und verletzter
nachmittag in der türkei in der
grenzstadt nusseibeh schlug eine von
syrischer seite abgefeuerter granate
mitten im ort ein
die türkische militär offensive gegen
kurdische milizen in syrien hat nach
angaben aus ankara bislang mindestens
neun türkischen zivilisten und drei
soldaten das leben gekostet
auf der anderen seite wurde unter
anderem die kurdisch syrische stadt
kamischli von türkische artillerie unter
beschuss genommen
auch hier verletzte und tote die
türkische armee setzte ihre angriffe
heute mit unverminderter härte fort
inzwischen befinden sich mehr als 70.000
zivilisten auf der flucht
wir müssen weg kinder werden beschossen
sie sterben und niemand hilft
hilfsorganisationen warnen vor einer
neuen humanitären krise die menschen
fliehen ins landesinnere vor allem ins
100 kilometer südlich gelegene arag die
behörden dort richten gerade vier große
notunterkünfte ein und wir versuchen
lebensmittel dahin zu schaffen
eine diplomatische lösung des konflikts
ist nicht in sicht
in frostiger atmosphäre musste sich
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg heute
in istanbul den vorwurf mangelnder
solidarität anhören
stoltenberg rief die türken zur
zurückhaltung auf und er warnte vor
weiteren gefahren der militäraktion an
immer wir haben unmittelbar die sorge
dass inhaftierte terroristen des
sogenannten islamischen staates
ausbrechen könnten
deutlichere worte fand der europäische
ratsvorsitzende tusk bei einem besuch
heute in zypern
die einseitige militär operation der
türkei in syrien ist äußerst
besorgniserregend und sollte sofort
beendet werden
ein rasches ende der kämpfe ist aber
nicht in sicht
wir schalten jetzt direkt ins
grenzgebiet zu syrien in die türkische
stadt aktuelle wo sich unser reporter
thomas gill befindet thomas in diesem
gebiet finden ja bisher die heftigsten
kämpfe statt wie ist die situation im
augenblick ja wir sind hier auf der
türkischen seite und 200 meter von mir
ist die grenze da ist die grenzstadt el
aber ja das ist ein hauptfokus der
offensive die wird der ganze tag wurde
hier schon heftig geschossen artillerie
beschuss von der türkischen seite und ob
die stadt eingenommen wurde können wir
noch nicht sagen eingeschlossen ist sie
in jedem fall was wir auch wissen dass
das krankenhaus dorthin teil aber jetzt
dass das geschlossen wurde weil die
menschen weil dort kein personal mehr da
aber überhaupt ist die stadt verlassen
und man muss jetzt sehen wie sich die
situation entwickelt die türkische armee
ist auf dem vormarsch die 67 kilometer
im landesinneren und was wir gehört
haben dass oft allein auf syrischer
seite haben wir etwa mehr als 300 300
tote und wenn es jetzt dunkel wird dann
wird von der anderen seite geschossen
nämlich von syrischer seite richtung
türkei in die stadt axa calais und
gestern ist eine granate in ein haus
gefallen und dort sind eine mutter mit
zwei kindern sind dort tödlich
verunglückt vielen dank für ihre
informationen thomas gill und das
gespräch mit dem kollegen gill haben wir
aus sicherheitsgründen noch bei
tageslicht am späten nachmittag geführt
das ziel seiner politik fast äthiopiens
ministerpräsident ahmed in einem wort
zusammen mit dem adhs in seiner sprache
versöhnen zusammenbringen und das hat er
geschafft die belohnung dafür
der friedensnobelpreis 2018 übernimmt
ahmed das amt und hat einen plan frieden
schließen mit dem nachbarland eritrea
nach 20 jahren feindschaft und einem
krieg in dem rund 80.000 menschen
starben
also reicht er eritrea die hand grenzen
wurden geöffnet getrennte familien sahen
sich wieder aber der weg zur versöhnung
ist ein langer berichtet tim kröger
es waren unglaubliche szenen als elfter
september 2018 der grenzübergang sallum
wasser zwischen äthiopien und eritrea
geöffnet wurde und er hatte das möglich
gemacht
der äthiopische premierminister und neue
friedensnobelpreisträger abu ahmed der
bereits kurz nach seinem amtsantritt
offiziell frieden mit dem erzfeind
eritrea geschlossen hatte die mauer die
zwischen unseren völkern in den
vergangenen 20 jahren gegen ihren willen
aufgebaut wurde muss zerstört werden als
rasse mittlerweile sind die direkten
grenzübergänge zum teil wieder zu aber
der vernichtende grenzkonflikt bei dem
rund 80.000 menschen ums leben kamen ist
offiziell beendet
in der hauptstadt addis abeba heute viel
zustimmung bekannt für krieg und
hungerkrisen jetzt aber richten sich die
augen wegen des friedensnobelpreises auf
uns ich bin stolz äthiopien zu sein
mit der selbst aus den früheren
repressiven staatsapparat äthiopien
stand hat zudem sein eigenes land
geöffnet inhaftierte journalisten und
aktivisten wurden freigelassen verbotene
parteien rehabilitiert
allerdings seien reformkurs hat auf die
ethnischen spannungen massive gewalt und
machtkämpfe geführt dennoch der frieden
mit eritrea hat vor allem auch
hoffnungen auf die beilegung anderer
konflikte geweckt the peace frieden
zwischen äthiopien und eritrea
profitiere nicht nur diese beiden länder
sondern auch tribut die somalia und zu
daher so dann noch aber hat der junge
premierminister ahmed einen weiten und
schwierigen weg vor sich
20 tage noch dann soll ja für die briten
schluss mit der eu sein
nun gibt es überraschender weise eine
zaghafte hoffnung dass ein chaos exit
auf den letzten metern doch noch
verhindert werden kann
brüssel verhandlungsführer barnier ist
von den eu-staaten ermächtigt worden
noch einmal über ein austritt abkommen
zu verhandeln
zuvor hatte er mit seinem britischen
kollegen barclay beraten ob es nicht
doch noch ein licht am ende des tunnels
geben könnte ich ja eine gellinek in
brüssel was geht denn anlass zu der
hoffnung dass der scheidungsvertrag doch
noch rechtzeitig unterschrieben werden
kann
tja der anlass ist eine kleine
trendwende auf britischer seite seit
gestern bekommt die eu signale dass die
briten jetzt doch dringend am abschluss
eines austritts abkommens mit der eu
interessiert sind und seit gestern seit
dem ball sonst seinen irischen kollegen
berater getroffen hat scheinen die
briten auch bereit zu sein dafür rote
linien zu verschieben boris johnson
denkt offenbar darüber nach nordirland
in einer partnerschaft zu belassen das
wäre eine enge anbindung an den
binnenmarkt dadurch könnten zoll und
grenzkontrollen entfallen eine position
die boris johnson bisher abgelehnt hatte
beide seiten wollen jetzt intensiv und
hinter verschlossenen türen verhandeln
das ganze wochenende vielleicht sogar
bis zum eu-gipfel nächsten donnerstag
ob das reicht um einen deal zu schließen
und ob es klappt das bis zum 31 oktober
durchzuziehen
oder ob man nochmal eine verlängerung
dafür braucht das alles heute abend noch
offen aber diplomaten hier in brüssel
sagen es herrscht keine euphorie aber
doch eine zarte hoffnung dass ein deal
auf dem letzten drücker
vielleicht doch noch möglich sein könnte
sind wir mal gespannt vielen dank anne
gellinek ein kleiner fehler mit großer
wirkung weil ein dichtungsring kaputt
ging musste eine molkerei heute
frischmilch zurückrufen von zehn großen
supermarktketten deutschlandweit bei
einer routinekontrolle in diesem berg in
nordrhein-westfalen fiel der fehler auf
aber da war es schon zu spät solche aero
monas bakterien waren in die fettarme
milch gelangt keime die
magen-darm-probleme wie durchfall
auslösen können mourinho erklärt welche
produkte betroffen sind in dieser milch
produktionsanlage in everswinkel
gelangten die keime in die milch im
kondenswasser über einen defekten
dichtungsring ein großer teil der
kontaminierten milch wurde an fast alle
großen lebensmittelhändler ausgeliefert
die größte deutsche molkerei ruft
bundesweit verschiedene marken zurück
wir können aufgrund dessen dass wir das
problem relativ schneller kannte aber
inzwischen auch schon längst behoben
haben die chance relativ gut und genau
eingrenzen dass wir den verbrauch
tatsächlich sagen können welche produkte
er nicht verzehren soll
tatsächlich kann der hersteller bisher
keine genauen angaben machen wie viel
liter und wie viele packungen mich
betroffen sind es geht ausschließlich um
ein liter packungen frische fettarme
milch mit 1,5 prozent verbraucher die
einen dieser angegebenen artikel gekauft
haben erhalten auch ohne vorlage des
kassenbons den kaufpreis zurück
betroffen ist die milch mit folgender
kennzeichnung und eine
mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum zwischen dem
zehnten und dem 20 oktober
wir beraten auf jeden fall davon ab
diese milch zu trinken oder auch im
müsli zu verzehren
auch davon die jetzt selber zu erhitzen
oder so was raten wir auf jeden fall
auch ab also die milch muss zurück zum
handel
ärzte empfehlen auf jeden fall auf
symptome zu achten bei einem leichten
durchfall sehe ich eigentlich gar keine
notwendigkeit tätig zu werden beim
schweren durchfall würde ich mich dem
arzt den hausarzt beispielsweise
vorstellen auf den konsum der milch
hinweisen dann kann man in der
stuhlprobe nach dem erreger suchen
lebensgefahr besteht aus medizinischer
sicht nicht anders als bei listerien
oder salmonellen gehört die milch in
meinem kühlschrank zu den betroffenen
produkten auf heute de können sie noch
einmal nachlesen um welche markennamen
haltbarkeitsdaten und supermarktketten
es geht dass wir jetzt über den 14
zu-null-sieg der iranischen
männer-nationalmannschaft berichten
liegt allein an den frauen im
fußballstadion
denn nach fast 40 jahren durften
iranerinnen zum ersten mal ins stadion
zur guten nachricht gehört allerdings
auch eine schreckliche vorgeschichte der
freitod von sajani die
fußballbegeisterte hatte sich im
september selbst angezündet weil sie
fürchtete wegen des unerlaubten besuch
ein besuch seines spiels ins gefängnis
zu müssen christoph distel wenn schon
geschichte schreiben dann richtig bunt
und laut sind sie auf dem weg zum spiel
4000 karten für frauen gab es in einer
stunde war das kontingent weg und
tatsächlich sie dürfen ins stadion gegen
den willen der erz konservativen denn
die bleiben dabei halbnackte männer auf
dem rasen fluchende männer auf den
rängen das sei nichts für frauen
ich habe das verbot nie verstanden wenn
frauen dabei sind werden sich die männer
doch zivilisierter verhalten das haben
wir auch anderswo im kino auf der uni
auf der straße auf der tribüne geht die
historische party los zwei stunden noch
bis zum anpfiff die frauen unter sich
und doch euphorisch denn dies ist ihr
erfolg sie machten bei der fifa druck
bis die dem iran mit einem ausschluss
bei der wm in katar drohte und der gab
schließlich nach zähneknirschend
natürlich glauben wir dass frauen ins
stadion dürfen aber und sie wissen
sicher was ich meine
einen teil der gesellschaft stört das
einfach frauen im stadion
diesen teil männer und frauen
demonstrieren in teheran gegen den
tabubruch vor vier tagen war das also
nur ein paar wochen nach dem tod von ca
das gefängnis hatte ihr gedroht nur weil
sie sich als mann verkleidet in stadion
geschlichen hatte sie wählte den freitod
17 uhr
das spiel beginnt gähnende leere trend
frauen und männer aber sie sehen
zusammen das selbe spiel keiner weiß
wohin diese erzwungene geste irans führt
den nationalteam aber haben die frauen
schon mal beflügelt wie gesagt 14 zu
null
mal sehen wie es weitergeht
und nun zu dir norbert unserem tennis da
hat zverev einen wie heißt er mit
vornamen alexander es wäre auf einen
wichtigen sieg aber er hatte ja jüngsten
echte schwäche phase gehabt viel auf
weltranglisten platz sechs zurück heute
bei den shanghai masters aber ein ganz
starker auftritt des 22-jährigen sieg im
viertelfinale über den grand slam
rekordsieger roger federer
emotionen bestimmen das spiel der
generationen alexander zverev sehr
effektiv 17 asse schlägt der deutsche in
einem hochklassigen match roger federer
ungewohnt diskussionsfreudig in sachen
schiedsrichter entscheidungen
der 38 jahre alte schweizer hält zwar
dagegen aber zverev macht die
entscheidenden punkte
der matchball endete ebenfalls ungewohnt
mit einem fehler des 20 maligen grand
slam siegers 6 2 3 6 7 6 zu 3 12
trifft im halbfinale auf den italiener
matteo bettine die mercedes piloten
valtteri bottas und lewis hamilton haben
das zweite training zum großen preis von
japan in suzuka dominiert fünfter
sebastian vettel hinter seinen
ferrari-kollegen le claire
das qualifying wurde übrigens von morgen
auf sonntagvormittag verschoben wegen
eines nahenden taifuns nach der
dopingsperre für alberto salazar
chefcoach des nike oracle projects hat
der us-sport konzern jetzt die
schließung seines leichtathletik camps
angekündigt betroffen ist davon auch die
deutsche wm dritte constanze
klosterhalfen wie sich jetzt neun monate
vor den olympischen spielen in tokio
eine neue trainingsstätte sie zur toren
wm in stuttgart da stand heute das
mehrkampf finale der herren an
und da gab es einen russischen doppel
erfolg
nikita nagorny heißt der neue
weltmeister im mehrkampf der 22-jährige
aus rostov am don zeigt an allen geräten
eine konstant starke leistung mit hohen
schwierigkeitsgraden andreas toba wird
als einziger deutscher finalteilnehmer
neunzehnter der hannoveraner und bester
deutscher allrounder tour nach
durchwachsenem start von gerät zu gerät
stärker silber hinter weltmeister
nagorny geht an arthur dalyan hier links
ebenfalls russland bronze an den ukraine
war nicht das was vor mir dann genau was
das wetter morgen ist zweigeteilt sonnig
im süden grau und nass im norden was das
wochenende sonst noch zu bieten hat weiß
gleich christa stück so viel von uns
danke für ihr interesse
claus kleber erwartet sie heute um 20
nach 10 zum heute journal
und wir sind morgen abend wieder hierzu
stelle um einen entspannten start ins
wochenende
[Musik]
gegen abend heute gab es große kontraste
es war nämlich einmal sonnig im süden
wie hier in oberbayern im norden dagegen
grau nass und windig wie hier in rostock
warnemünde und so zweigeteilt geht es
auch jetzt weiter heute nach dem süden
vier bis zehn grad bei aufklaren in
südbayern 2 im norden 12 bis 14 grad
denn hier liegen eben noch die dichten
wolken mit anfangs kräftigem regen und
teils stürmischem wind je weiter wir
richtung süden kommen desto
sternenklarer wird der himmel und genau
diese grenze ist morgen vormittag noch
etwas schärfer nördlich einer linie
münsterland nordbrandenburg ist es grau
und wieder nass wobei es insgesamt
weniger wind oder auch weniger reden
gibt als heute aber südlich davon
strahlt wieder die sonne
wobei es nachmittags im südwesten
interessant wird da kommen nämlich ein
paar mehr quellwolken wahrscheinlich
aber nur einzelne schauer
dazu gibt es 14 bis 19 grad unter wolken
22 bis 25 grad schon mit sonne im süden
und am sonntag sind dann sogar 26 27
grad möglich vom oberrhein über franken
bis zur saale auch im norden dann ein
paar sonnen auflockerungen und 20 grad
wobei es im nordwesten immer noch
schauer und vor allem nachmittags
gewitter gibt und in der neuen woche
wird es von westen wieder wechselhaft